welcome to this glamour special with me
editor-in-chief Deborah Joseph and with
me today I've got a really amazing
inspiring a special woman Nicola
Mandelson thank you for joining us it's
so happy to be here
Nicola is VP of Facebook amia and also
just for full disclosure is also my
sister-in-law but also as well as
everything else that you have in your
life you were also diagnosed with
incurable blood cancer three years ago
which was a massive blow to you to me to
everybody around you I wanted to go back
to the day that you were diagnosed what
happened what symptoms did you have gosh
it's it's exactly three years ago when I
first found a lump and it was a tiny
lump it was until you remember I wasn't
ill at all I was living kind of this
extraordinary life busy at work busy
with the kids busy with the family and
tiny lump it was like about this size in
my groin and got a friend who's a doctor
and I phoned her and I said I found
alone what do you think she goes don't
worry lumps come and go with women I
didn't go I've always been quite in tune
with my body checking my body so I went
to see her and because I know her I
remember seeing her face when she you
know looked at it and I said you don't
like it do you
she has I'm not sure what it is I don't
know but let's get you checked up by
someone I went to see a gynecologist is
who she sent me to and he examinee he
thought I was all right and I literally
had my coat on and he said you know what
while you're here wouldn't do any harm
to do a CT let's get a CT scan just to
be sure I'm gonna went home didn't think
anything of it a few hours later I saw
that I had lots of missed calls from the
doctor and also from my friend I
remember going to talk to John my
husband and saying I think this is bad
news and I phoned my friend and she said
he have you spoke to the other doctor
and I said no she said well I'm coming
around right now
she said we we can see tumors up and
down in the inside of your body but we
don't know what it is
so you need to get a buy up so you need
to see what happens so that's where it
started and then it was a weekend we
can't get anything done on a weekend so
it was literally we didn't tell anyone
we didn't tell anybody in the family
it was just John and I at that point
because we thought better to know what
we're dealing with and also it was our
damn ease our son's 18th birthday the
following weekend so you don't think
rationally it was horrendous horrendous
horrendous weekend I just thought of all
the worst things that could possibly
happen I lost half a stone in weight
from worrying and not sleeping and
crying and trying to put on a facade of
normal all at the same time and on the
Monday had to have a PET scan and then I
went to see hematologist to find out
what was really going on had a biopsy so
within a week I was actually diagnosed
which is actually very unusual for a
blood cancer blood cancer often people
can go 2 to 3 years getting more sick
getting more symptoms which get
especially for women get passed off as
oh you're tired is that the menopause or
you're having night sweats that's the
menopause you're doing too much don't
worry and actually sometimes these
things can be actually blood cancer and
did you have any symptoms absolutely no
symptoms I haven't had any of those
symptoms three years on I haven't had
any other symptoms so that some people
get them some people don't I didn't get
them Wow so what happened then
so I got the actual diagnosis that I had
a blood cancer and it was non-hodgkins
follicular lymphoma which is something
I've never heard of most people can't
say and it's actually the most common of
the non-hodgkins lymphoma but at that
point my mindset was all around well
I've got to beat this you know when you
hear about cancer you you hear about the
fact that you know you'll cut it out
you'll blast it with you I mean you'll
get better I started to do research into
and the course of initial treatment that
was being recommended was to start chemo
that week which was sort of what I had
expected but as I started to do research
on it I actually saw that there was no
change in your overall life expectancy
if you treat now or treat in the future
makes no difference it still grows
slowly and there is actually something
called watch and wait something that
patients actually call watch
Woori which is where the doctors monitor
you but they don't actually do anything
and they see how the progression of the
cancer is growing for me I was able to
go for 18 months watching and waiting
until the point at which some of the
tumors had grown near my kidneys and
they were worried about actually whether
it was going to block my kidneys and
give me kidney failure which is when
they decided I needed to start treatment
I mean I remembered that day well I
think when they told you needed chemo
was the first time I really saw you
break down and show massive emotion
because you were just so strong I will
never forget the day you came around to
my house it was a Saturday and you walk
through the door and I just I knew
straightaway something was going on
because you just didn't have your normal
face and we sat in the living room and
you said to me and I don't I've got
cancer but if you're going to get a
cancer this is a good one to get what
made you think that what made you say
that there can be a good life expectancy
for people with this cancer so you can
live 20 years it might be longer that
bit is all a blur I remember very
clearly telling you know being with John
getting that initial diagnosis I
remember clearly telling the kids and
then all of it is a bit of a blur what
do you say to kids in that situation
that's really hard and you know it's
hard rethinking it I have to say we we
got the kids all together you know we're
a close family you know that we are and
we were they will it was Sunday morning
it was about eight days after I've been
diagnosed I mean I was very emotional
I could really found it hard to get the
words out John was very helpful to kind
of help get through the conversation you
know the kids just look sad and then Zac
who's our youngest who was 11 at the
time just turn around and said are you
going to die I need hugs can we hugs I
need lots of hope for so I'm gonna do my
very best not to I didn't lie to him all
the advices be honest and so we were
honest I mean the interesting thing
about this cancer is it's invisible you
look probably the best you've ever
looked in your life
everyone says Nicol looks incredible
Nicola looks incredible and there's such
a weird irony to that because
obviously you've got incurable cancer
how do you manage that response from
other people and sometimes I think I
don't treat you as a sick person I don't
I treat you exactly the same as I always
have is that the right thing is that the
wrong thing how how are you finding the
way people are reacting to you I don't
think there's any rules here I think you
have to take your cues from each
individual person who's going through
each individual circumstance and how you
feel on one day might not be the same as
another day I was very lucky that when I
did have my treatment I was able to
tolerate it well I am lucky that I
happen and I haven't really had any
lingering side effects from it when I
went on watch Amway was that the best
thing I could do knowing that I was
going to need chemo can imagine knowing
that you're going to need chemo and it's
coming to you at some point we don't
know when but probably on average within
two years you're going to need chemo so
what can I do what can I be in control
if I can't be in control of the disease
what can I be in control of and so the
doctor said get strong just get strong
you know all the things that were always
told eat well do your exercise and then
when you need chemo your body will
recover quicker I just try to be a bit
kinder on my body so that when I did
take treatment I would be able to
tolerate and recover stronger from it I
also know I'm fortunate and not
everybody that has this cancel everyone
has this treatment is as fortunate as I
am I mean just a very basic thing I
remember before you started your chemo
you went and bought a wig you know you
were sending me photographs of you in
different wigs and which one's the most
likely best match to your hair and
actually you didn't even need it in the
end because you didn't really lose your
hair which I think again in terms of it
being an invisible cancer because you
didn't look like you were going through
chemo it was difficult to know how to
treat you that yeah I agree
again I'd read a top tip which said
don't wait till your hair starts falling
out to buy a wig get it beforehand and
then it will be a nicer experience I
mean it was still it's still a very
traumatic experience to go and get a wig
because you know you're going to lose
your hair but it's again not all chemos
are equal and I knew there was a chance
with this chemo that I could lose that
my hair but also I knew it could thin
and I didn't want to take the risk so it
did thin my hair did then this is all my
hair and you know it does grow back and
mine's pretty much grown back more or
less
not quite as big as it was but that's
what he does matter to people mattered
to me how I felt and so I have this wig
it's that there and I'm very happy that
I've never had to use it the thing that
surprised me the most about your
response to your cancer was you actually
started opening your mind to alternative
treatments what what made you change
your mind and also what did you do that
surprised you I tried everything I went
a reflexology acupuncture I did had a
look at all the vitamins and minerals
and whether I was deficient in any of
those things and so yes I've embraced a
lot of different things bit of
mindfulness just reading everything I
can do you think they made you feel
better I think it gave me a purpose to
do something so I didn't feel powerless
but I was also very clear and I said it
with my doctors at the point in time
that I needed treatment I would stop
anything that looked like it had the
potential to interfere so I stopped all
the vitamins etc where did you find the
most amount of support from I think I
found the most full support by just
living my normal life and actually just
getting on with doing the things that
I'd always done I mean there was that
initial kind of flurry at the beginning
looking back now I wasn't as present as
I'd like to be and I think Adam my
husband also feels the same but I think
when you're such a strong person we
didn't almost we didn't want to make you
feel weak by constantly treating you as
a different person you know if I
suddenly start to bring you every single
day it would have been a bit strange do
you work out you were always there and
if I ever needed you I knew I could
count on you but I know you found a lot
of support in Facebook groups you set
one up or you joined one that always was
already in existence it was about three
months after I was first diagnosed and I
suddenly thought if there's a Facebook
group that has anything to do with this
and lo and behold there was one it's
called living with follicular lymphoma
and it was only recently set up three
years ago had a few hundred members by a
lady called Nikki living in Australia so
I sent her a DM saying hi my name is
Nicola Mendelssohn I'm the VP for mayor
at Facebook I have follicular lymphoma I
think it could help and actually become
really good friends really good friends
and together we've now grown in this
group to be 6,000 members strong which
is incredible because one of the reasons
no one's found a cure for your cancer is
because they deem it
to be small a small cancer and also one
that only affects older people
yeah it's classed as a rare cancer
there's less than a million people
living with it in the world
so the 6,000 strong of us now it's the
largest group that's ever existed of
follicular lymphoma patients in one
place and it is the single best place
for advice and support and top tips and
you often see people putting in posts in
there that go I just need to rant X Y
Zed I know you'll all understand sort of
thank you for giving me the space people
are just there for one another
how did Facebook respond to your illness
because you know when people get ill
sometimes they're forced to take a step
back because they don't get the support
from their employer how was it for you I
couldn't have wished for a better place
to be at work and to have a diagnosis
like this I was instead take the time
off whatever you need we are here for
you I was like no that's the worst thing
I definitely don't want that I'll just
be sitting at home all day and just
thinking about my mortality I do look at
you sometimes I think how do you you are
always happy you're always positive
you're always doing something how do you
manage that how have you managed to do
that I think because I've always just
lived my best life possible I've always
felt very grateful for the life that I
have the family that I have the friends
that I have the opportunities that I
have and I really saw the darkness of
what happens when you allow your mind to
wander and I know that's it's an easy
thing to say cuz it's so easy to do that
spiral down you know if I get worse if I
get ill who's gonna be there and then
suddenly you're in the worst place
possible and it's hard it's hard to get
out of that pit it's a pit of misery is
a bit of despair and it pulls it pulls
you physically I mean it made me
physically ill I could see the physical
consequence and I just thought that's
not me I am NOT going to do that that's
not how I want to live my life however
many days weeks months years I have I'm
gonna live my best life possible I think
it's fair to say you are living your
best life possible but even to the point
I think when you got diagnosed maybe we
thought maybe she'll slow down will she
keep will she keep her job I think it's
the opposite I think you're working
harder you're doing more incredible
things you're even now trying to find a
cure for your cancer with your own
foundation did you ever think I will
take a step back or was it never even an
option no it's definitely not an option
because it goes back to do I want the
cancer to define me and the answer to
that is no absolutely do not everybody
kept saying to me amazing advances in
medicine you know they'll be a cure
don't worry don't worry and as I started
to do more research as I started to meet
people in the field what became very
clear was that actually that cure wasn't
going to be coming very soon because
there wasn't much awareness and there
wasn't much money going into it and so
that's why I decided that actually if
not now who and if not me then who else
at this point in time and so I hadn't
expected to set up a charity but yeah
the follicular lymphoma foundation it's
now I think I mean you are one of the
only people I know who will get an
incurable cancer and their response to
it is I'm going to find a cure obviously
you're now doing this huge launch which
is why we're doing this interview what
do you need to do how much money do you
need to raise and how can people help
you raise it I need to raise a lot of
money it starts by people being aware of
it so follicular lymphoma follicular
lymphoma that you know it's out there
it's a real thing for the people living
with it
it's tough it's really hard we have a
website that we've just launched which
the addresses there flf no org on there
is lots of advice for patients for
family members and crucially it's a
place where you can donate money so
please please go there we also have a
Facebook and Instagram pages as well oh
well as will support your glamour in any
way we can thank you so much love you
say
you